bienvenue à paroles est anthony cissé
mais sa mort lundi depuis 7 semaines
j'ai reçu une question de la rance qui
me demande pourquoi est ce qu'il ne faut
pas se déguiser en indien alors oui
laurence déjà ta question elle le dit
bien
l'indien entre parenthèses c'est un
fantasme je parle pas de l'indien qui
vient de l'inde
ça c'est une nation carrément mais
l'indien c'est souvent là être à plumes
avec un petit point que des peintures de
guerre ou la pocahontas sexy c'est ce
qu'on voit comme déguisement qui est
très souvent vendus dans les magasins de
darwin et que l'on veut absolument
éviter alors lwin parce que on encore
cette discussion là même au québec sur
l'appropriation culturelle sur aussi
quand je vois la destruction de l'image
des premières nations comment elle est
réduite à un fantasme très simpliste
alors que chaque nation justement des
regalia c'est à dire des habits
traditionnels qui sont très distincts
les uns des autres et qui nous servait
même nous à nous identifier entre
nations
deux autres tu viens de telles
communautés je vois des mocassins
ils ont fait comme ça et c'était une
manière de pouvoir montrer fièrement
doute une mais quand s'est réduit à le
petit kit en cuir c'est de dire que
carrément t'as pas de nation tu n'es que
l'indien tu n'es que qu'un fantasme
donc c'est certain qu'il faut totalement
éviter les costumes d'halloween qui
représente une nation une entité
culturelle parce que justement ça peut
être souvent des grands d'europe et est
même insulter des gens qui sont présents
ça veut pas dire d'aller aborder des
mamans et des papas dans la rue parce
que leurs enfants sont déguisés en été
c'est qu'on fait des concerts des
conversations qu'on doit avoir en
communauté en société mais cependant
cédé comme des conversations qui sont
très différentes d'une nation à l'autre
et je pense juste quand les gens se sont
déguisés en geisha et que des japonais
au japon ont pas vu du tout de problème
mais que des japonais aux états unis qui
ont vécu les camps de concentration de
la deuxième guerre mondiale qui avait eu
aux états unis eux y voyant un problème
c'est une question de relation pouvoir
aussi et cette discussion là est très
difficile à voir parce que quelqu'un va
me dire un peu moins d'orange
quant aux dirigeants aux bûcherons mais
je pense que ta relation avec la
personne qui se déguise en bûcherons à
différents que pour une première nation
qui voit encore la réconciliation comme
étant quelque chose de non accomplie
alors il faut éviter les glissements il
ya plein d'idées beaucoup plus
intéressante qui peuvent être
développées comme costume d'halloween et
attendre que justement on soit tous sur
le même pied posé on peut se déguiser
l'autre parce qu'on se respecte
mutuellement
ça va être une autre relation pour dans
quelques décennies alors j'espère que
laurence allard répondu à ta question
j'espère que vous allez partager ses
vidéos et vous avez envoyé d'autres
questions est ce pas cet automne